when my dad goes to work he does really
important stuff
he stops bad guys and keeps everyone
safe
when people are in trouble he saves the
day
[Applause]
am i the only one who wished that wasn't
a dream the boys episode 5 is here and i
gotta say this was one of my favorite
episodes so far
there were so many references and jabs
and i'm here for it
in this video we'll be going over some
new theories how stormfront may be
pulling the strings on a huge setup
and if you're lucky logan will even whip
up some precious memes
so grab your favorite pig smash that
like and subscribe button cause here we
go welcome to the set of dawn of the
seven the biggest over-the-top sjw film
of all time
i'm a lot like you
i'm gay and this episode goes gloves off
on how big companies like disney promote
diversity but
often don't really give a [ __ ] using it
more as a political tool to gain points
rather than creating authentic and
genuine stories
that feature characters from diverse
backgrounds just look at john boyega's
scathing critique of what disney did to
his character poe in the star wars
franchise
or how lesbian kisses are often
relegated to background actors
and homelander is just firing on all
cylinders this episode girls get it on
done girls get it done or how about this
jab at dc and the justice league
joss rewrite really sings huh this
episode focuses heavily on homelander
we've seen how his public image has been
tanking while his envy for storm front
rises
he'll lose the public's trust when his
killing of an innocent is caught on
camera
so what they're all starving but one of
them's got a [ __ ] cell phone
homelander tries to ease the situation
himself by interrupting congressman
newman who is a huge outspoken figure
against big corporations like
vaught and homelander her character is
based off real life congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez
didn't you love that little walk like an
egyptian dance you did online
so fun aoc went viral a few months back
for her dancing
stormfront once again offers her help
and how about this for some sex
foreshadowing sex shadowing well i'm
here when you want me
butcher is a complete mess after his
wife becca decided not to run away with
him he even starts a fight getting the
crap kicked out of him to feel something
at a nearby pharmacy he picks up a pack
of homelander peas
under a vaught fresh farm sign by a
maeve and starlight cutout and let's not
forget the
seven plush toys one of homelander he
ends up buying so his dog tear can [ __ ]
it
but this episode really digs deep into
the relationship between huey and
butcher
the two complement each other as we'll
find out from butchers and judy
huey is a lot like butcher's younger
brother lenny butcher would always stick
up for lenny and lenny would always reel
him back
in and calm him down the show doesn't
explain what happened to lenny when huey
asks judy where he is she just says
oh god rest his soul in the comics lenny
was killed by a bus
in 1986 however it's uncertain whether
he could still be alive in the show as
mother's milk said in episode 3
huey is like butcher's canary alerting
him to when he's gone too far
when he risks getting in danger just
like canaries alerted miners to the
dangers of the mine like poisonous gases
butcher however is done he's off to
argentina for an early retirement but
first he'll need to stop
off at his aunt judy's to pick up his
dog frenchie follows kimiko who i guess
is now specializing in face peels she's
actually doing jobs for the albanians
through his [ __ ] buddy sherry this is
like a double betrayal for him as he
sees his love go down this dark path
and his friend using kimiko for her own
game when
just last episode he vented all his
feelings about this situation
when confronted kimiko lashes out she
feels responsible for the death of her
brother
and killing others is her way of coping
if she's gonna change she'll need to
open up to frenchie
teach him her secret sign language she
and her brother used to communicate
and realize she wasn't the one
responsible for her brother's death
until she's ready to do that
well frenchie puts it this way he'll be
a monster
the deep is on his whirlwind press tour
after his marriage to cassandra schwartz
who we met last episode in her marriage
interview
this is all part of the church of the
collective's plan to revitalize his
image we even get our first glimpse of
the head of the church
alistair adana in one of their ads
someone who will likely play a bigger
role in
episodes to come now i visited
churchofthecollective.com and it takes
you to the boy's website maeve will
later come to the deep looking for his
help but
what exactly she wants isn't yet known
but it likely has to do with taking down
homelander
we're gonna take that [ __ ] down
the deep will need a woman like me
to be on his side if he's gonna get back
into the seven and she needs someone
like the deep if she's gonna protect
elena since homelander outed maeve on
live television he's been a specter over
their lives
and maeve is concerned for elena's life
and not to mention the insanely
contrived lesbian image
vaught has constructed for maeve and
elena's relationship americans are
more accepting of gays when they're in a
clear-cut gender-role relationship like
ellen and porsha atring shows the
director his revised dialogue which
makes it seem less like he's leaving the
seven
and more like he's just going away for a
while and some of these are
actually pretty hilarious if you zoom in
you can see but the truth is i've been
running my whole life and i'm not sure
where i'll run to next
i understand you're an amazing hero a
train you deserve the best and i look up
to you you're the greatest hero
i know where's atrain heading off to
next not sure
i wouldn't count me out just yet atran's
put in his place by ashley who says if
he doesn't go through with the approved
script he'll be outed for using compound
v
a breach of his morality clause in his
contract he'll get
nothing butcher arrives at his aunt
judy's she's actually in the middle of a
drug deal
she runs a drug den in her basement for
old people needing prescriptions
and can we just talk about how amazing
this russian debate over which musical
is better
clearly dear evan hansen kimiko here
just takes bullets like they're nothing
kind of like black noir does later in
the episode he also survives several
bomb blasts
speaking of black noir he's like the
worst at hiding if butcher and the gang
are going to take him on they'll need to
buy themselves some time which is why
they call the fire
department for a fake gas leak
stormfront has brought starlight's mom
to set
we saw her last season and know she gave
starlight compound v without her consent
and was an overbearing stage mom that
put her in hero pageants starlight has a
lot of resentment toward her mother and
doesn't like the fact stormfront is
meddling in their relationship this is
because
stormfront knows it was starlight who
leaked the compound v
story to the press later in the episode
she'll call her out for it which
starlight says
if she does she'll out her as being
liberty huey gives butcher a pep talk
how can butcher be giving up when
there's so much at stake
hughie didn't give up when robin died
robin you'll remember as huey's
short-lived girlfriend from the very
first episode
but butcher isn't having it you're so
scared of being alone
huey first you let you under robin then
starlight and now me well you know what
son
i ain't interested butcher wants to be
alone because he knows that he can't get
hurt if there's no one to hurt him
but he needs to understand that one has
to risk getting hurt for those you love
stormfront and atran have a little chat
where we learn she used to be a
church-goer but
not anymore that place used to be pure
and then they just started letting all
kinds of people in
some people are quality and others are
garbage she is straight up racist to the
max here as she drinks out of a cup that
says
storefront homelanders attempted
appeasing the crowd at his protest
goes terribly wrong when they boo him if
he's gonna change his image he'll need
stormfront's help she'll get one of her
interns to create some fire memes
oh this is just the first batch i'll
have logan punch up the fear
this is a total jab at those far right
memes you'd find on your uncle's
facebook
stormfront's been setting up a lot of
stuff this episode starlight and donna
homelander and this scene with
lamplighter who is credited just as a
man in scrubs and it's here we can
basically confirm that the soup who made
agent rainer's head explode a few
episodes back
is someone who is a patient at sage
grove center
someone who is ordered by stormfront no
one ever said the job was easy
look he's just a kid 17 years old you
don't got to look him in the face
this kid is feeling sorry for what he
did but stormfront says he's a hero
we'll likely see him next episode black
noir makes his move on the house the
bombs the boys preparing having no
effect on him butcher takes him on but
he's no match
even the bullets mother's milk and huey
dish out at him have no effect so
butcher has to use his last
card blackmail for black noir if noir
kills any of them he'll leak photos of
homelanders secret bastard son to the
world
a son who is conceived through rape and
that's when black noir gets a call from
stan
edgar who's been watching a call whose
ringtone is handel's messiah
it's literally a call that becomes the
boy's savior here
edgar agrees to let them go in exchange
for the photos to remain a secret
starlight breaks into stormfront's
computer using the password adele to
gain
access adele is stormfront's mother's
name with all the theories going around
about stormfront and her connection with
frederick vaught perhaps her being
related somehow i'm wondering if this
adele shown in this picture is her
mother at all remember that liberty
doesn't age and should be in her 70s or
80s
so this being her actual mom is unlikely
i'm still thinking stormfront is related
to frederick vaught somehow maybe this
could be her sister or even a complete
fake to prop up her ruse as stormfront
and not liberty starlight finds
numerous emails from sage grove the same
place lamplighter works much of the
emails are blurred out but we can make
out things like
82 success rate and phase timetables
this place seems to be a testing ground
for soups perhaps even one run by vaught
to continue performing experiments
just like frederick vaught did at dachau
i think stormfront is planning something
nefarious with vaude
after all it was stan edgar who made her
part of the seven and we really don't
know where she was
all these years she definitely has some
sort of plan and is putting all the
pieces in place
and i can't help but think this plan is
in coordination with edgar even after
encounter with starlight
she says to her you're gonna be a big
help to me so she obviously has
something planned even more concerning
is her fight slash sex scene with
homelander it looks like she has him
right under her finger hey at least
homelander can warm up all the milk he
needs now don't be a [ __ ] laser my
[ __ ] tits
well we do know strong older females are
his type i think we can all agree
stormfront isn't in love with
homelanders she is gonna use him
and damn is this breakup gonna hurt and
finally we have a complete change in
butcher the events of this episode have
inspired him
not to give up on becca he tells his dog
i swear to god i'll kill you
earlier he talked about how him becca
and tara were supposed to be a family
so the mom here is referring to becca
but just exactly
how he'll get her back remains to be
seen thanks for watching everyone please
make sure to like and subscribe and
while you're at it give me a follow on
twitter and instagram at thingstoryt for
more bad takes
until next time remember daddy's home